it's not easy watching your children
leave says
the mother of two whose children are
among the millions of Cubans now living
in the United States
I'm desperate to go to them the
situation here is getting worse every
day I'm alone in the country and there
are no medicine there are long lines to
get food I need to be with my children
this is not what I expected I gave my
life for this country but not anymore
Midas father fought in Fidel Castro's
Revolution now she's waiting for her
children to apply for a U.S government
reunification program that allows
residents to bring their family members
from Cuba to America
has also left she too is alone and
waiting for the same Visa
there's so much stress I live on my own
that the situation is sad the hospitals
are horrible there is no medicine we get
only seven eggs a month I live on my
pension but I can barely survive on it
her pension is around eight dollars a
month Mayra and Maria Del Carmen are
proof of a new reality in Cuba where
young people go abroad in search of a
better future leaving their relatives
behind
annually say that by 2030 the average
Cuban will be 60 years old
Cubans are leaving the country in record
numbers U.S government figure shows that
over 250 000 Cubans enter the U.S
illegally in a period of 13 months this
is almost three percent of Cuba's
population here in Havana people are
also coming to foreign embassies to try
to find a legal Pathway to other
countries
the economic situation is the driving
force Rising inflation a shortage of
food medicine prolonged power outages
and a trade embargo turn life into a
daily struggle
many have lost hope that anything will
change the opposition blames the
government
what is happening now is a crisis
generated by the government salaries
have lost four or five times their
purchasing power soaring inflation was
caused by the government by a
reorganization of the currency and the
government knows it did not work and of
course they'll never say they got it
wrong and will blame U.S sanctions for
the problem Cuba has prided itself on
its Universal care and education system
but the increase in migration has
presented A new challenge an aging
population people who are too old to
leave but unable to survive if they stay
there is Cuba